well I don't know if the radical fairy
thing is a movement I've been to some
gatherings a lot of my friends the
gatherings you know friends live in this
common like environment I'm not so much
hardcore into that but I really
appreciated that that input of my life
of people who think that you're you know
queerness which I define is not
necessarily having to do with sexuality
you can certainly be straight and be
queer to me it's like an understanding
of the world that isn't limited by
received notions of genders like looking
at the world through a prism of
understanding the fluidity of gender and
sexuality which can manifest itself in
humor and art you know sort of queer
sensibility or it can also affect how
you look at even you know the way you
interact with the earth you know what
the world when you understand there's a
fluidity perhaps you integrate your life
more with how you know perhaps an
interaction a more sustainable way with
the earth or and I'm not sure how that
necessarily transmitted itself but it
does in this in the radical fairy
movement or community and so I learned a
lot from people who lived in these
communes and on the gatherings that had
kind of a queer Burning Man feeling and
it's much less ageist and those tends to
be more men I could do it the more with
a more diverse you know diversity and
gender I think the the more mix of crowd
the better the party you know in terms
of because when there's too many men in
one space you get too much of that
energy of sexual energy or kind of
competitive
just as too many perhaps too many women
in a room there's a different too much
sameness doesn't always make a good you
know it's not a good recipe for for
balance but I do appreciate their
understanding that you know being
different is it the privilege you know
it's not I don't necessarily feel a
pride in being different in that way but
there's a pride in what you do with it
you know and certainly shame can be can
rub off from culture and self-hatred can
rub off from culture and fear of you
know misogyny and femininity and men and
you know all these these things that
make you not like yourself when you're
young
can't oddly that separateness can be a
great mine of material when you're
seeking to create yourself as an
individual unfortunately the more
acceptance there is yes just fewer kids
killing themselves now because of the
internet and and acceptance of gays in
the world is a natural variation but
there's also a real embarrassing kind of
conformism that comes with acceptance
you know acceptance and assimilation you
know breeds mediocrity and perhaps an
even more sheep like conformism in terms
of what kind of music you're supposed to
listen to if you gave what are you
supposed to look like what's your body
supposed to look like how are you
supposed to have sex how you supposed to
vote you can get very boring and very
you get a lot of unexamined lives and
that's unfortunately the the result of
assimilation and acceptance but it's one
that has to happen if
to be more happiness I think being queer
is not enough certain is not interesting
enough and this probably there's a lot
of great beautiful people in the world
and good people but there's fewer people
that this may be 0.01 percent that is
actually interesting whether they're
straight or gay or whatever because
they've chosen to forge their own way
examine their life a bit more and not
settled